come on I believe that today we're going
to talk about how you can lead and
inspire your people too many talented
and gifted leaders go on unnoticed in
the world never had a chance to hear
from them because they allow themselves
to become negative they allow themselves
to become volunteer victims they allowed
themselves to focus on the problem
rather than the possibilities Jim Rohn
said when the incomes of you let it find
you conquering a new mountain not
sliding down an old one you got to
continue to stretch continue to grow
continue to expand Socrates says a man's
reach is to supersede his grasp or what
are the heavens for we have far more in
ourselves but we've got to challenge
ourselves we have to engage in that
process
most people just talk they go so far and
they Park and they coast out to the
sunset who you are as a person comes out
and shows up in your leadership so I
believe it's about personal empowerment
becoming aware of who you are
self-awareness and what is it that
drives you what is it that motivates you
what is it that you want is cultivating
a sense of goodness and greatness within
yourself
great leaders envision a compelling and
different and vibrant future than what
is here they have an alternative clear
view of what the world could be like
tomorrow then it is today right they
have a shared purpose they believe that
they and others would be compelled by
interested inspired by and want to work
towards and that's a big deal and you
always read about in leadership right
you have to have vision
I mean it's biblical where there is no
vision people perish right we know the
power of having that vision so you have
to sit down though and actually do it
the reason we say envision versus just
have a vision is you have to sit is it
it's a practice of envisioning what
should tomorrow look like for my team
what should tomorrow be like for my
business for my organization what should
tomorrow be like for my life and not
just tomorrow a long-term mindset and
view the dream right that magnificent
obsession that that bold desire the
moonshot goals and purposes and missions
of life the bigger picture that's
envisioning a different reality in the
future than we experienced today and
that's what everybody gets excited about
in leadership or there's no vision
there's no leadership where there's no
vision people perish you see the
greatest motivational principle in the
world the greatest motivational
principle in the world is that people do
what people see and too many too many
travel agents too many travel agents
they're like um or too many leaders
too many leaders are like they're like
travel agents they're sending people
where they've never been themselves and
you want to be a tour guide you want to
take people with you you want to say
this is the area where I've been this is
where I live this is the area where I
lead come along and follow me and at
level number three your leadership
begins to gain credibility because now
you are fleshing out for the people
around you and you are modeling for them
things that they want to see and you are
starting to produce which something else
happens because you're becoming
productive in your own life you begin to
attract people that begin to be
productive also in the 21 irrefutable
laws of leadership that I wrote one of
the laws is the law of magnetism and the
law of magnetism just says we attract
who we are not who we want so when I
talk to leaders often when we talk about
recruiting then I'll say well what kind
of people do you want in your company
what kind of people do you want in your
department as a supervisor and they'll
give me a list they'll write things you
know I want I want somebody that's I
want somebody this self-discipline and I
want somebody that is service oriented
and they'll get me a UH you know a list
of four five qualities and since they
give me the list Knight I look at those
qualities in and then I ask him a very
simple question I say okay uh do you
possess those qualities you can see on
level number three basically who you are
as a leader is who you attract on your
team number three I call it the three I
practice the three I practice if you
want to be a lot better leader
understand and then practice these three
eyes number one inspiration the job of a
leader really is to inspire other people
if you look at Steve Jobs you look at
Elon Musk you look at Nelson Mandela you
look at Sergey Brin of Google you look
at a Rembrandt or or a Picasso these
people were incredibly inspired they
were not only incredibly inspired they
were inspirational to other people I
mean there's that incredible story of
Steve Jobs and
a lot of people say Steve Jobs wasn't a
nice person and yet if you were to pull
the former employees of Apple they would
say my years at Apple working with Steve
Jobs were the single best years of my
entire career and you say why and they
say because he was inspirational I mean
when Steve Jobs was a young man or a
young kid you know his father said go
out and paint the fence outside of their
house and Steve Jobs said no problem he
went out and he started painting the
outside of the fence a few hours later
his father comes out and says Steve did
you paint the fence Steve says I did
that Steve Jobs his father inspects the
fence and he says Steve you did a great
job painting the outside of the fence
but he didn't paint the inside of the
fence and Steve Jobs looked up at his
father and says but Dad no one's going
to see the inside of the fence and
father looks at them and says but son we
will now its many decades later and
Steve Jobs is running Apple and they're
ready to launch already to develop
rather the first Apple Macintosh and he
looked at his design team and he said
here's your deliverable I want the
outside of the computer to look so
simple and so elegant like a piece of
art but here's the real mission make the
inside so beautiful that it'll bring
tears to our eyes and his design team
looked at him and said but Steve no
one's gonna see the inside of the Apple
Macintosh and Steve Jobs looked at his
team and said but we will
that's inspiration I think the only
title that really matters is CIO chief
inspirational officer so no matter what
you do whether you're a teacher or
firefighter an astronaut or an
entrepreneur maybe you're managing
director maybe your mother or a father
be the CIO the chief inspirational
officer if all you do the second eye if
the three I practice to make you an
amazing leader is influence influence
you want to be so good at what you do
that you influence other people you want
to use the words and the language of
leadership versus victims speak you want
to influence people by your mindset by
your heart say you want to influence
people by your thinking patterns you
want to influence people by your
productivity so you want to influence
people and that's the job of a leader
and then the third eye if the third eye
practice impact less talk more do no
matter what your title is you know
you're leading you know you're winning
when you are creating impact you know a
lot of people in the world and victims
love to do this they talk about what
they're gonna do here's the project I'm
going to launch here's the marathon I'm
gonna run here's the life I'm going to
craft but they don't execute impact is
about translating your ideas to
execution so leadership is not about
personality is sure in fact some of the
greatest leaders we studied had a
charisma bypass
and we should never confuse charisma
with leadership they're very very
different ideas some of them are even
odd and eccentric one of the great chief
executives of the last 30 years is Herb
Kelleher of Southwest Airlines he solves
a trademark dispute with an
arm-wrestling contest it's just not
normal he would talk about wearing a
flowered hat in a feathered boa around
the office just strange this is not
personality the key to the great leaders
that we studied was their humility
but it was humility of a very special
type it wasn't humility in just in a
weak sense it was in fact just the
opposite it was what I would describe as
an absolute obsessed burning compulsive
ambition that wasn't about them an
absolute burning compulsive ambition for
a cause for a company for the work for a
set of values not themselves an
inability to translate that ambition
that subjugating themselves to something
that is not about them into a series of
decisions very willful decisions and
this is why I look to Lincoln as our
great president in the United States
because he was ambitious first and
foremost that the nation must endure and
he had the will to endure the most
brutal war in all of our history
with all of it during his tenure and to
lose his life you become a motivational
leader by motivating yourself and you
motivate yourself by striving toward
excellence by committing yourself to
becoming everything that you're capable
of becoming
you'll motivate yourself by throwing
your whole heart into doing your job in
an excellent fashion you motivate others
by continuing looking for ways to help
them to improve their lives and achieve
their goals you become a motivational
leader by becoming the kind of person
that others want to get behind and
support in every way your main job is to
take complete control over your own
personal evolution and become a leader
in every area of your life you could ask
for nothing more and you should settle
for nothing less
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because William Chilton
asked me to so there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in the next edition of
believe life leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the clips
had the biggest impact on you and why
what issues you're facing in leading
people to greatness for leading yourself
to greatness leaving the comments below
and I will join in the discussion
finally to give a quick shout out to
Anna Bernanke from what is PTSD calm and
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book it really means a lot to me
if you guys watch it if you want your
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to grab a copy of the
book and also email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever you're one where it
is and I'll see you soon
speed of the leader speed of the group
you have got to buy into it you've got
to believe it the difference between
leaders and and and people that are
followers leaders it's a it's a whole
different standard for them you know
they it's a different between being in
the business and the business being in
you that it has to be who you are and
that you set the pace for the
organization if the leader become
cynical if there's any doubt if you
don't have absolute faith that you can
make it happen if you become cynical if
they sense that you don't believe that
it can happen if you start complaining
about the fact that you can't get your
higher-ups to answer or there's so much
political bureaucracy that we have to
deal with that you're frustrated that
you don't know what to do that you're
pulling your hair out that you can't
sleep at night because of the fact that
it's out of your control if you have
that victim mindset and feeling
powerless
that nonverbal communication your facial
expression your energy the spirit of who
you are that will permeate and
contaminate the spirit of the
organization many leaders their
effectiveness with their people their
impact their influence begins to
diminish because they don't take the
time to shop in their minds to build
their faith to build their skills to
empower and increase their confidence in
themselves so part of what we have to do
all leaders you have to take time to
pour into yourself and you've got to
also reach out you've got to have a
Board of Advisors and it's your support
committee that will give you a home
court advantage more teams win on at
home than they do on the road 87 percent
why because they have people cheering
for them I think that all leaders should
have people around them their group
their mastermind group that will help to
pour into them there's safety and
counsel that they can talk to one of the
things I always tell leaders that ask
for help not because you're weak but
because you want to remain strong and
ask for help and don't stop until you
get it the best leaders on the planet
grow other leaders so if you're not
growing leaders faster than your peers
you're not leading you're following I'm
going to repeat that again the job of
the leader is to grow more leaders so
yes do your
work yes become more creative yes
innovate yes optimize your personal life
and yet at the same time make the time
to develop leaders around you what that
might look like at the office
celebrating a teammate at the office
that might look like modeling mastery at
the office it might look like
collaborating with someone who needs
some collaboration at home what does
growing the leaders look like well it
might be mentoring your children
exposing them to art giving them great
books it might mean being a positive
force in your home life so the job of
the leader is to grow more leaders you
can't lead others until you lead
yourself think it's a Manfred kit to
freeze phrase and I believe it but so
this purpose your resilience your
ability to absorb shocks disappointments
you know there's a you you can how to
manage your energy I have now believe in
you got to manage your energy not your
time forget a time it's hard to manage
your time I think yeah it'd be good if
you could and I wish I could do it
better I think actually what's more
important is how you manage your energy
what's a source of energy for you what
sucks energy away from you and making
sure you've got that right balance in a
day to be able to deal with it
your physical fitness I mean you you
know this is a Carlos Cohen has talked
about this you know he's a guy as being
a CEO for 12 years he's sort of in my
view straddled both eras the old era and
the new era and he talks very eloquently
about you know the you know the
disciplines he has to have it used to be
the case you know you'd do an overseas
trip and he's a guy living in sort of
four cities around the world you get a
day to recover you know now there's no
way all leaders today you you land you
operate you know you're scrambling
you're trying to pick stuff up how do
you keep your your energy there so you
don't make any rash crazy decisions